[Music]
on this Wednesday night the fight
against inflation the Bank of Canada
holds its key interest rate steady for
now this is good news but is not job
done what needs to happen to prevent a
recession
standing in solidarity taiwan's fight is
Canada's fight what's at stake is China
threatens to reclaim Taiwan the power of
electric vehicles
what's driving up concerns about the
risks to pedestrians and other motorists
and toxins in toys they can remain in
your blood in your lipid tissue for many
years the harmful chemical lurking in
some children's products
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about interest rates
and inflation the Bank of Canada did not
raise its key rate today it's holding
steady at 4.5 percent where it's been
since January after Rising nearly
non-stop since March of last year but
the Bank of Canada Governor warned today
it could hold at that level for a while
or even rise again because inflation
hasn't cooled as much as he'd like in
our top story tonight Ann gaviola
explains what that could mean for you
the economy is expected to grow modestly
even as inflation comes down
this is good news but is not job done
the head of the Bank of Canada
describing a scenario in which inflation
comes down but Canada avoids a recession
but a lot needs to happen to get us
there Canadians perception that
inflation will stay high needs to change
wage increases must stabilize and
businesses need to stop hiking prices
acadians should expect more rate holds
to come unless there's some surprising
data in the months ahead the perception
that this may be the end of the bank's
tightening cycle May boost the housing
market I think it will instill some
confidence in home buyers and even home
Sellers as well too it kind of signals
that we may be at the end of these rate
hikes but the central bank is leaving
the door open to more hikes if needed to
tame inflation if monetary policy is not
restrictive enough to get us all the way
back to the two percent Target we are
prepared to raise the policy rate
further to get there on the heels of the
recent collapse of three regional banks
in the U.S and the bailout of Credit
Suisse a systemically important Bank
many wonder if that's prudent this week
the international monetary fund warned
of economic turbulence lurking beneath
the surface especially for the world's
wealthiest Nations we have though for
quite a while now talked about high
levels of household debt being a
vulnerability and it is something that
that we need to watch Market Watchers
expect a rate cut by Year's End bringing
the bank of Canada's key interest rate
from four and a half percent to four and
a quarter percent but that could come
with a recession or economic downturn
now Macklin says that is not the most
likely scenario but as we've seen in
recent weeks a lot can change on a dime
Donna sure can and gavioli in Toronto
thanks wages are a major sticking point
for 120 000 Federal public workers who
their union says have voted
overwhelmingly in favor of strike action
our members wages have been stuck in
neutral while the cost of living
continues to soar
we're asking for decent wages that
prevent workers from falling further
behind the public service Alliance of
Canada one of this country's largest
unions says its members including trades
people Coast Guard workers and clerks
have been without a contract since 2021
they're now in a legal strike position
as well 35 000 federal tax workers will
be in a legal strike position on Friday
the union says it still wants to reach a
deal with the government
prime minister Justin Trudeau answered
questions today about China's latest
military drills around Taiwan
China's aggressive actions in the Taiwan
Straits and around Taiwan are
problematic and we really hope that
there will be a de-escalation of
tensions in the region we will continue
to stand for our values we will continue
to stand up for democracies everywhere
around the world
the Prime Minister made the comments as
a group of Canadian MPS met taiwan's
president today to voice their support
Jeff Semple is in the Taiwanese Capital
tonight Jeff
Donna the Taiwanese president met last
week with U.S officials enraging the
Chinese government which launched three
days of military exercises around Taiwan
well today it was Canada's term to
engage in high-stakes potentially
provocative diplomacy
like old friends reunited Taiwanese
president saying Wen welcomed a
delegation from Ottawa 10 MPS from
Canada's four main political parties we
don't always agree on everything but in
in this circumstance I think it's very
clear that all parties agree that that
support for Taiwan is important they
presented a report passed unanimously
last month by parliament's special
committee on Canada China relations it
called for closer ties with Taiwan and
an end to Chinese military aggression
even as we arrived here there's 160 war
planes flying over ahead and they're
carrying on Naval exercises our message
to them is that
taiwan's fight is Canada's fight while
Canada's concern is focused on the
Chinese government's alleged foreign
interference Taiwan faces the prospect
of a military Invasion by Beijing which
considers the island nation its own
Canada is a very important Democratic
partner the Taiwanese president said
faced with continued authoritarian
expansionism it is even more critical
for democracies to actively unite
opinion polls have consistently shown
the vast majority of Taiwanese want to
remain a democracy separate from China
but these high-profile meetings with
Democratic world leaders have proved
polarizing here some feel the photo ops
aren't worth beijing's wrath this issue
has been divided in Taiwan as well
because something this is kind of too
provocative against China the leader of
taiwan's pro-china reunification party a
former convicted gang leader says the
Canadian delegation should go home
they should mind their own business and
solve their own problems before talking
about these things he says
maybe I should tell Canada how to deal
with its indigenous people are you
worried that this visit might further
provoke the Chinese government not at
all because these visits are part of
long-standing policy what has changed is
beijing's position they've become
increasingly belligerent with their wolf
Warrior diplomacy and we can't we can't
appease that behavior by cow Towing to
it past visits by Canadian politicians
to Taiwan like the one just last year
have largely focused on issues such as
trade and the economy but the
conversation this time is different
talking security and defense this
relationship being reshaped by an
increasingly bold and Brazen Beijing
Donna Jeff sample in Taipei Taiwan
tonight thanks Jeff Russia is being
accused of committing more atrocities
two videos posted to Russian social
media have Ukraine comparing Russia to
the so-called Islamic State Global News
is not independently verified the videos
we're not going to air them in full what
they appear to show is disturbing
including a Ukrainian prisoner of war
being decapitated by a Russian soldier
as Crystal gomancing Reports Ukraine's
president claims it's part of a grim
pattern the world cannot ignore
Global News is obscuring the images as
they are simply too disturbing for
broadcast a man in a military-style
uniform kneels on another pinning the
victim down as he saws at his neck with
a knife
there is something that no one in the
world can ignore how easily these beasts
kill Ukraine's security service has
opened yet another war crimes
investigation because of the videos it's
not known who made or posted them to
social media the Kremlin spokesperson
described them as awful and called for
their authentication
in the world of fakes that we inhabit
says Dimitri paskov we need to check the
veracity of this footage
in the beheading video another
individual is seen grabbing a flak
jacket and showing the camera the
Ukrainian Trident patch in a separate
video there is what appears to be a
destroyed armor personnel carrier and
two bodies visible without heads the
videos are likely a few months old as
the ground is dry and there's Greenery
in the frame the grizzly recording
surfaced just days after Russia took up
the presidency position at the un's
security Council each member state gets
a month-long rotation the Ukrainian
foreign minister tweeted saying it's
absurd that Russia which is worse than
Isis is presiding over the UNSC
on the front lines neither side appears
to be gaining or losing much ground in
bakmut it's been the site of one of the
bloodiest and longest battles since
Russia launched its full invasion of
Ukraine 14 months ago
zielinski says Terror must be defeated
in Ukraine and as he highlighted the
horrors in the video he again called for
the world to support his soldiers
Crystal gemancing Global News London
the American president has begun a
three-day political and personal visit
to the Republic of Ireland and Northern
Ireland and called for political
compromise
today
I come to Belfast to pledge
to all the people of Northern Ireland
the United States of America will
continue to be your partner in building
the future
the young people of our world deserve
it matters to us
to Americans
and to me personally President Biden is
extremely proud of his Irish heritage
two of his great-grandparents are Irish
he spent the first half of the Day in
the UK meeting with the British prime
minister Rishi sunak before heading to
the Irish Republic for meetings with
officials and distant relatives Biden is
there to celebrate the 25th anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement but the
power sharing government it established
has broken down and hasn't met for more
than a year
as electric vehicles become more common
on the road their incredible weight is
posing new risks to other drivers I'm
Jackson crossko ahead on global national
we'll take you along for a craft test
in the U.S state of Indiana a fire at a
former recycling plant has prompted
evacuation orders for thousands of
people there are no reports of injuries
but because of all the plastic at the
facility authorities warn it will be
days before the fire is out officials
say the building's owner was warned
multiple times about unsafe conditions
the U.S Environmental Protection Agency
has proposed some of America's toughest
Federal automobile pollution rules if
approved the new rules would not set a
quota on electric vehicle sales but
rather mandate limits on greenhouse gas
emissions depending on how automakers
comply the EPA projects that at least 67
percent of new passenger vehicles sold
in the U.S would be electric by 2032 EVS
make up less than six percent of cars
sold in the U.S right now
as more electric vehicles hit the road
there's growing concern about the risks
they could pose in a crash EVS can be
heavier than gas powered vehicles
especially as range is extended and
batteries get bigger Jackson prosco
takes us along for a crash test to see
how EV safety is being evaluated
yeah it's testing day at the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety in Virginia
where they're preparing crash dummies in
a vehicle loaded with sensors and
cameras
what's different about today's test is
that it involves an electric SUV which
thanks to its massive batteries is far
heavier than your average gas powered
vehicle
at test time the vehicle is catapulted
down the track and into a wall
simulating how the car and its occupants
would fare in a head-on collision what
we found is that overall their safety
performance has been been very good safe
for their passengers but because of
their enormous weight there is growing
concern about what happens when EVS
crash into other cars and pedestrians
how much extra weight are we talking
well in this electric SUV the battery
pack alone makes up about a third of the
total weight nearly a thousand kilograms
that's approaching the entire weight of
a compact car anytime you have very big
Mass disparity in a vehicle-to-vehicle
crash the laws of physics have not
changed
the occupants and the lighter vehicle
are always going to come out worse as
automakers bring out more electric
models the number of bigger heavier
vehicles on the road is growing rapidly
I am concerned about the increased risk
of severe injury and death
for all Road users from heavier curb
weights the U.S national Transportation
safety board is increasingly worried not
just about the weight of EVS but also
their incredible acceleration
the 4 000 kilogram electric Hummer can
go from zero to 100 kilometers per hour
in just three seconds simply the
acceleration that's enabled by Electric
batteries and their Motors
is a problem there's so many scenarios
in which that speed and that
acceleration is just dangerous to others
on the road the Auto industry argues
customers want the range that only big
batteries can deliver in fact a new
generation of lithium-ion phosphate
batteries is about to roll out in
vehicles everywhere they're even heavier
than the batteries used today it sounds
like there's still a lot to learn there
is absolutely a whole lot to learn what
I'm hopeful for is that some of these
vehicle masses don't keep going up and
up that we can have some lighter
batteries with you know maybe faster
charging times until then researchers
will continue to put EVS through their
Paces making sure that trying to solve
one problem hasn't created another
Jackson prosco Global News Rutgersville
Virginia
[Music]
had the final answer on whether Harry
and Megan will
it Buckingham Palace has ended months of
speculation over whether Prince Harry
will attend his father's coronation the
palace confirmed today Harry will be at
the ceremony on May 6 though his wife
Megan will stay behind in California
with their children princess lilibet and
prince Archie it's Archie's fourth
birthday on Coronation Day Harry hasn't
been seen with the royal family since
his book detailing family backstabbing
jealousy and dysfunction was published
and since the couple's Netflix docu-ser
series was released Harry has said his
Royal relatives have so far shown no
willingness to reconcile
well all parents know the challenge of
keeping little kids from chewing on or
eating things that are unsafe and assume
things we buy for babies and infants are
safe researchers at the University of
Toronto have found that's not always the
case they found high levels of toxic
chemicals in electronic devices clothing
and children's toys chemicals that have
been banned in Canada for a decade
Catherine Ward explains what researchers
discovered and what it could mean for
you
I got a lot of the product samples from
volunteers around my lab I just asked
them to bring in whatever they felt
comfortable taking a piece of the study
that I also went to Dollarama and I just
slept a bunch of stories off the shelf
and uh analyzed those researcher Stephen
katarna's analysis found short chain
chlorinated paraffins a chemical that
has been banned in Canada with limited
exemptions since 2013 because of risks
to the environment and human health the
chemicals are not supposed to be in toys
results from this study showed they are
there we found uh quite high
concentrations of these compounds in
toys meant for children and toddlers And
particular teething boys out of 96
household items tested 84 had the toxin
chemist Carl Jobe says part of the
concern is that the compound doesn't
break down easily once you've consumed
them by inhalation of dust through hand
to mouth contact with the you know
electronics that you're playing with
they can remain in your blood in your
lipid tissue Advocates are calling for
more accountability retailers need and
manufacturers need to be testing and
demonstrating safety and that retailers
need to be demanding that information
and enforcement we don't have a strong
toxic slaw that enforces this Universal
principle that retailers are on the hook
for what's on their shelves and that
there are strong laws that protect us
and protect particularly Children's
Health we asked Dollarama for a comment
about the findings and it provided a
statement saying product compliance is
its utmost priority and it is committed
to improving testing Dollarama also says
it has been working with manufacturers
to eliminate certain chemicals and heavy
metals even within allowable limits in a
statement Health Canada told Global News
it is reviewing the study and will take
appropriate action as required Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
ominous off-season next with the Toronto
Raptors face ahead of the NBA's play-in
tournament
[Music]
it seems there is no limit on what some
people will pay for sports memorabilia
these are Michael Jordan's last dance
sneakers worn in game two of the 1998
NBA Finals they are now the most
expensive shoes ever sold at auction it
went for 2.2 million dollars U.S that
smashes the previous record for a pair
of Air Jordans sold in 2021 the
basketball Legends Final Season with the
Chicago Bulls was dubbed the last dance
and the Chicago Bulls are the first of
two teams the Toronto Raptors must be to
keep their NBA season alive the Raptors
weren't good enough to guarantee a spot
in the postseason that puts them in
playoff purgatory and as Eric Sorensen
explains there's lots on the line in
their first ever play in game tonight
I'm an NBA champ
those Halcyon Days when the Raptors were
perennial contenders in every
post-season Hope Springs Eternal for a
return to Glory even if the team is not
what it once was I'm excited to even
just have a uh a shot again at being in
the finals this year players often had
to explain away a mediocre season just
overall low energy low
compete level and it seems a loss of
confidence over the last 10 years the
Raptors finished near the top of the
Eastern Conference every year usually
top three until the last three seasons
12th Fifth and 9th ninth under a new
play in format does give the Raptors one
must win opportunity against Chicago a
win would mean another must win one game
against Miami and then they would earn
the uninviting distinction of starting
the playoff series against the NBA's top
team Milwaukee the players are ready if
not brimming with confidence season up
and down
um having a great opportunity but it's
impossible I'll stay in the postseason
there is a different Aura around this
Raptors team the play-in game begins
what could be a turning point a
franchise preparing possibly to break
apart so different from four years ago
when the pieces came together to win a
championship in 2019 the team's
executive Masai yujiri orchestrated a
huge trade for Superstar Kawhi Leonard
and with other additions the Raptors the
city of Toronto and the country soared
to the top of the basketball world we
gotta you know get some guys to to bring
some energy and play with play the right
way now a different tone from the coach
and rumors abound that some of the Stars
could leave this summer there might be
some Changing of the Guard there's been
reports that potentially Nick nurses
looking elsewhere Fred Van bleet Gary
Trent Jr and yaka Purtle can all walk in
the summer if they choose to fans like
Junaid Shaw are prepared for change we
lack a superstar right now so even if we
make this run I don't feel like it's
going to be deep the Raptors season
could end abruptly but for basketball in
this city it has been a long and
triumphant run Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that's global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
Euro Canada is Bronte Harbor in Oakville
Ontario we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]